hey John what King Arthur I'm like
another sword final trailer this is the
movie I've been looking forward to all
day John and I actually did a reaction
and a full like 15 minute review of this
of the last trailer we just got the
camera fix and the mic settings are off
it is the video set a way to loud
Oh that'd like we were screaming into
the mic no matter how well we spoken no
matter how much I lower the volume I
remember that was a bummer because that
was a good discussion discussion because
the trailer like what is over yeah yeah
right here we had a lot of like like
sauce why why why we thought it wouldn't
look good at all of that gave us a lot
of oh so let's see if this trailer can
do the same for us final sequence do I
traitor in other videos I'm still
recovery mode right now John little sick
- yeah cute cute guys this is the first
ones naked is real oh man let's uh
defend it the panel
I'll get my coat and you know sort of a
king and then yourself find you what
kind of man would you become had you
inherited your father's Kingdom instead
of being raised in a brothel okay Jesus
try
[Music]
is the Guy Ritchie movie
[Music]
he didn't
it was bored again who murdered your
father
but what we can account for is what you
can do with this sword if power is
increasing when people fear you
intoxicated sensation to keen and give
me a rough landing
[Music]
for the Baba doesn't it make the palace
burn well
[Music]
nice to you action things look really
cool it they look really cool those
action sequences look pretty pretty
pretty pretty good
oh yeah I mean guy and Guy Ritchie is a
pretty good visual artist it seems like
yeah most def mos def oh yeah I wish she
was in this stuff eel King Locker a
little BQ cake hey hey hey we can we can
repeat some of the things we sent him
the one that way you can doing it early
dude we can one thing I'm liking oh
Jesus he's on the phone you apply for
one loan three years ago and you get a
billion phone calls for you later
do you need more money right there are
doing way too much interest on can we
pray on you some more anyway King Arthur
and the round table of the sword watch
one thing I really like you well we're
talking about there I'm really liking
that this is strictly a king our third
story
it's a Guinevere and Lancelot aren't
even credit as characters in this movie
and when I hear King Arthur its I
usually think King Arthur and the
knights of the round table so you know
rather that liking the cartoon I watched
Camelot
when I was really young were than many
other iterations like the original
classic kind of disturbing King Arthur
man children should not watch that movie
with what King wanted like Cooper no not
that one
what are you talking about Excalibur
Excalibur tower yeah the caliber was
like the beautiful but disturbing when
you were young I was not ready for our
children for that either I was a kid I'm
so glad to have so many different pg-13
versions you get on board with so I mean
I Excalibur's the best one they might be
too elegant I got a literally yes the
best one it's probably the most of a
film I still I still hold the director's
cut of the camera through movies
few years ago it's pretty good I mean
that's the kind of standard I feel like
I mean this does does does look cool I
don't I didn't think this is cohesive of
a trailer it's the last one for whatever
reason I don't know it still got all
that crazy cool [ __ ] what I like about
it is that where this is really focusing
on King Arthur just his origin story you
know the rebel without a cause Arthur
before he decides like I don't want to
be a leader if I'm gonna be a leader by
the end of this movie then they're gonna
have our fragile : a beer lands log of
it yeah they make an appearance at the
end Merlin or some Oh Merlin I hope
Merlin makes an appearance mattad I'm
cool now it just seems like he's not
gonna really have that hard of a time
though like King Arthur looks like he
can't really harm the guy he's got the
Excalibur sword I don't know what was
bored again have powers or he's just
having numbers it's hard to say I mean
from this trailer just looks like he's
got an insane amount of soldiers at his
disposal yeah that King Arthur's just
going to pg13 them up you know but yeah
oh yeah but I think you see like I think
yeah I think blood and [ __ ] would put a
worth wait anytime it's a war movie like
especially what it's about carnage
didn't [ __ ] well man especially like
carnage with swords and yeah arrows and
stuff like it but nasty bass goes a
little bit in in fact full Lord of the
Rings kind of territory but it falls
under fantasy you know especially the
world of are like a sword ass caliber
and everything so even though this is a
little more toned it didn't see much
like huge and the mystical elements as
I'm used to but you got those giant
that's done Elephant Man yeah okay I
think it's funny now listen I've ever
said I've seen them at the the Los
Angeles Zoo yeah yeah next to the
giraffes they keep them in the same cage
also it's a simple story it's it's a
simplified version where we can get to
know King Arthur and his badasses we're
watching this sort of what makes him
become a leader to where then you can
get like the Arthur and the round table
I think that it is a cool franchise set
up
cinematic universe make your Lancelot
movie make your Guinevere movie make
your Merlin movie then bring them all
together for King Arthur and the knights
of the round table guys I'm telling you
if it's not a cinematic universe that
ain't worth anybody's time yeah yeah why
put a bunch of characters we care about
into one movie when you could just pull
one character we care about yeah in
front of a bunch of other characters
we'll never see again
spread it out yes spread it out milk
that money I want you wolf you save the
words universe and a [ __ ] ad will do
it spreading things thin and watering
things down I think is the key I don't
know I mean like it again yeah the
second trailer like won us over for this
so to speak might just be that cool was
that one person yeah copy images with
his emblem I'm probably just as
interested Allen as I was before like
this trailer didn't make me any more or
less interested you know it's got some
of the cool I don't know I guess what I
want to know is what makes this truly
distinct because especially during this
trailer especially I was watching the
clink that reminds me of 300 and that
reminds me of this movie and that
reminds me of something else and so I
just want to know what makes this this
Arthur special yeah and I also don't
know the mythology very well so I don't
know if this is a completely made-up
origin story or if this is in any way
based on no man it was all accurate to
the Bible yeah book of Arthur first
letter of Charlie Hunnam to Judas I
ended accounting good I mean Jude Law
it's kind of he never ages but he's kind
of perfect I think for a slimy cutthroat
King oh yeah he just played a just
played dick hope he did just land dick
oh yeah and kind of big dick ruler here
too you know
he's good at playing dicks and Charlie
honey I was watching this going man I
wish they cast him as Iron Fist
I think Charlie Hunnam live in a coop
like if they're gonna go well the white
boy route I think you could have gone
with Charlie Hunnam that's one of the
things I'm most curious about for this
movies I don't have a lot of experience
attempts my main association Charlotte
on him is Pacific Rim I'm very curious
about his capability as a leading man in
this kind level because King Arthur's is
literally a legendary character
Sons of Anarchy he's a badass character
Pacific Rim he's built like an action
star but he ain't doing really any
action in that movie it just looks like
he is here but not really doing him I
guess the way he's moving it really it
looks like he really trained to be like
to move like a fighters I'm not a real
bad yeah he looks like a total badass in
this I mean all that shots really
[ __ ] swiping dudes and screaming and
her like he definitely looks like he's
got the action shots my question is
acting I get what Pacific Rim was and so
it didn't take away from the movie but I
found him to be gritty wooden in that
movie and I and the only reason it
worked for me is because like I'm used
to that character being kind of wooden
so I don't know who but yeah what I'll
choice but I don't know I mean it might
have been a style choice for that
specific kind of film yeah cuz even in
crimson peak no crimson crimson tide Red
Dog you know I did alright job in and
crimson peak and I didn't watch Sons of
Anarchy but everyone who does says like
you got to watch it you just gotta stop
watching whatever show I told you to
watch briar what sons of that in order
to get everyone treats it and he's like
the star that Joe so when I imagine he's
a really cool actor and let's not forget
he was originally cast to be Christian
Grey but due to scheduling conflicts he
couldn't do it yes so it's good I mean
think about that for a second okay I'm
thinking about it imagine it my head or
they'd not being like re to violence
like when he's hitting them it still
looks cool like when he slashes and like
fly back I thought that was me you know
and if they were going like full 300
they would they would float through the
air as there's like slice here in his
blood get out of a little more fantasy
element to it when he's hitting them
I mean I'm sure not everyone's going to
get hit that way just a little bootie
boy yeah maybe maybe it already might
have been cooling I don't know guy
ritchie working with in pg-13 elements
for this I just always feel like Guy
Ritchie is going to be a little
restricted with a property like this in
a pg-13 environment a far be it for me
to say the guy rich you can't like you
know there's Sherlock Holmes seem to
have worked
and that's not a property that just
craves an hour rating you know yeah but
something like this I think it's more of
a challenge you know it's more of a
challenge to really sell it because a
lot of the time it seems like they just
kind of stack up on everything just say
like if we take all the blood it's fine
and I don't know it does at least for me
after so long of seeing so many of these
charred [ __ ] effects extravaganzas
where like you get to the finale just
batshit insanity so it would be nice my
batch insanity hope the goes gravity oh
there goes gravity children ok subscribe
to the real rejects yippee-ki-yay John's
reads so Jerry on Twitter and Instagram
and a lot of people requested this I'm
sorry I forgot to take photos of the
person who requested it but you guys
know normally I would do that but I have
a little on my off game right now John
is the social media manager of Oh
chicken teriyaki I kind of have a
craving just could eat something John's
woody what do you do for a living your
small or medium manager a blum house and
a coffee shop